- Listen, I'll be honest with you,
I'm emotional about it as well
because it is 100% my
biggest vulnerability too.
It might be at different scales,
people may look at like all this,
but I've left so much on the table.
Like I own nothing of Wine Library.
AJ owned 50% of this when
I had all the leverage.
Like, I've left so much and
my great fear is resentment.
- [Guy] Right, and that's what
I keep telling her is that,
here's the thing, I don't wanna look back,
it's give and then at
some point down the road
success meets opportunity, right.
It's one of those things
where I've planned,
even for like this moment,
I've shot hundreds of vlogs
hundreds of times, built all
these things and it's like,
you don't know when that
one time, that one--
- 'Cause I don't think
it's one time, to be frank.
My intuition is it's
getting into the pattern
of asking for what you're looking for
but being okay with not getting it.
- Right.
- Patience.
- [Guy] And making the video
content and nobody watches--
- And when you give,
giving means you have no
expectation on the other side.
Manipulating is when you give
with the thought you're gonna get.
And what people that love people that give
don't understand is it's
our natural DNA, the end.
- But as a wife she's going,
I just wanna see you win.
- But winning comes in a
lot of shapes and forms.
I'll be very frank with you,
if I do not buy the New York Jets
I would've won because
winning for me is the chase
of the New York Jets.
I've already won.
- You always say, the journey.
- 100%, like people don't wanna hear it,
I'll get booed when I'm
90 for not doing it.
- But do you care?
- Of course not
because that's winning for me and winning,
you know, spouses especially,
is a real tricky one,
it's of all the ones
it's the trickiest one
because they love you the most
and they're most tied into you.
So I have a lot of empathy
for the men and women
who have a spouse who's on the give train.
You know, you have to define winning,
if you've been giving this whole time
with the hope that some shoe drops
I have a ton of empathy for that
but you have to frame that in your head.
- [Guy] I think I give
because I wanna help people.
I'm a lot like you.
- Well then you've won.
But you have to ask
yourself, and it's okay
if you've been hoping that it leads,
that's unbelievably okay,
just as okay as somebody who always takes,
everything's okay.
You first have to ask
yourself, which one is it?
For me I will never let
anybody have leverage on me,
that is my happiness.
- [Guy] Well it's like
creating YouTube content
and then I don't really, I
create content to help and give
and don't make content to cave
to what other's expectations are.
- I get it, I get it.
I think deciding what winning
is is the most important part.
If you're hope is that all this giving
leads to business
opportunities, that's great.
I wrote a book called
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
I believe that that's how it does work,
but only in the macro.
I will never give to
her with the expectation
that she delivers for
me of something I need.
I'll be comfortable to ask,
I won't be disappointed if, like I've had,
I've told some stories,
unbelievable, I've given,
asked for something a tenth
of it, person didn't deliver.
You know, look, there's that initial,
like, fuck, and then you're like,
I don't have the capability of dwelling.
So I think the question becomes
for you, what is winning?
For me, no question, I'm about statues
and how many people show up to my funeral.
It's very clear to me.
- [Guy] I'll be there.
- And so to me, that matters.
Like, I wanna stun my grandkids
of how many people decided to show up.
The greatest day of my life
will be the first day I don't see it.
You know, I know that.
And so as you can imagine,
just giving is that leverage.
But if you're looking for some
short term financial reward
that's super acceptable,
what you need to make the change of then
is being clear about that,
because the cliche thing
I see in other givers
is they love the altruism that they give
but they have a burning
resentment and anger
or fear inside that they're not getting.
- [Guy] It's not that, it's I
kinda feel guilty to ask for
the monetary value, does this make sense?
- Of course, I'll tell you why.
'Cause you didn't ask for it up front
or set the framework for the
potential of it up front.
Which makes sense, right?
- Right.
- You see where I'm going?
That makes sense, because
if you didn't do it
now you know you're sandbagging the person
and that makes you feel bad, as it should.
I love that about you, on a quick read.
What you wanna think about
is is that macro work
leading to opportunity 'cause
somebody's word of mouth
or do you set it up in
the beginning and be like,
hey brother, I'll give you one video
but then I want you to buy
one video and that's great,
and would you like that or
no, and that's up to you.
- [Guy] And I have never done that,
I've just instantly given.
- And by the way, you've
gotten without even knowing
for that giving in many different ways.
The question becomes,
A, what's the difference
between you winning from your
eyes versus your wife's eyes,
but it starts with you
because your wife is taking
pillow talk and random
conversations and making it her own,
I know I gotta go, right?
You know what I mean, super important.
And here's the best part about 49,
you're at fuckin' half time.
And it's really hard to know that
because when you're 22 49 feels finished.
But when you're, think
about how young we all feel.
- [Guy] And I feel great.
- I wish he knew that
we feel the same as him.
Hold old are you, Jas, how old are you?
- [Jason] 23, uh four.
- Oh right, turned a couple days ago.
What 24 doesn't know is
when you're double the age
you feel exactly the same
inside, exactly the same.
You guys feel exactly the fuckin' same.
- [Guy] I still have
the same insecurities--
- That's right, it's the
same fuckin' everything.
- [Guy] Right, and here I am,
people ask me what do you do,
and I was like, I make videos
and I'm a YouTuber at 49 years old,
it's scary as hell sometimes.
- Yeah.
- It's fun.
- Just gotta ask, up front.
- [Guy] I do appreciate that.
- You know what I mean, I'm
like hey, I wanna sell sneakers.
And you seen how I do it,
and if you buy sneakers
then I'd like you to buy 'em.
But you don't have to and
you're more than welcome
to continue to consume my
content for free in perpetuity.
And as a matter of fact,
I'm so hungry to sell 'em,
I'm gonna give you a chance
to get what you really want
which is access.
(upbeat music)